people of the internets hello and
welcome back to harry potter in the
chamber of secrets
we are jumping right back in here
to our to-do list we need to rescue
neville
from behind the tapestry but before we
can do that
apparently we need to find the severing
charm
so surprisingly guys hermione did not
know the severing charm instead she's
actually
encouraged us to go out
at night at hogwarts and
basically we gotta go we gotta go get
this severing charm because neville is
stuck
behind the tapestry so i know some of
you have been uh
asking about this wondering when the
series is gonna come back because i i
have been posting one every week
but i think i'm gonna spread it out a
little bit more maybe two a month
something like that uh but basically i i
was ready to go with this one
and then we had some hogwarts legacy
news and so
this video got bumped it was actually
supposed to be last week
okay so i'm going to pull out the
remember all one more time here
find [ __ ] clump book find severing
charm so the book
of course is going to be in the library
which i believe
let's go back into the inventory screen
again let's let's check the map here
so grand staircase like okay this this
is not
when it's not labeled it's not really
helping me at all here
okay library annex how do we get into
the library annex
you know what we found it before we're
just gonna have to explore again
seventh floor yeah i mean it tells you
right here sixth floor ancient runes
non-magical studies history of magic
oh no come to me
what let me rip
you i mean obviously i know what this is
having read the books
but i forgot about it being in the game
jeez that is not pleasant at all
oh no hello there young harry where are
you off to such
dude right after that then here's nick
hermione it's urgent
so i'm afraid i can't chat for long not
to worry young harry
you cut along now and i'll see you some
other time good night
okay dick all right buddy we will
cut along indeed
all right charms and library here we go
so i know we're obviously gonna have to
sneak around here no no no stay back
where is the library which one okay
library index right here
all right now i remember this as a kid
being quite frustrating to get
through these sections let's see if it's
as bad as i remember so we have the
hogwarts prefix here
looks like this is a ravenclaw prefect
right there
all right so can i just i don't even
know if i need the wall sneak can i oh
no they're both over here what
and yet for some reason like hufflepuff
it's apparently purple in this game okay
we need to go now we need to go now come
on harry get around
the camera is so wonky right here at
this part is this it
am i there let's go door's locked oh no
this
okay let's is slip through right here
right here
i don't know where that other door goes
to perhaps we need to buy
alohomora for that one okay so now we
are officially in here
after hours so i don't know if we're
able to run around freely or not
[Music]
there's no wizard right there remember
the first time we came in here in a
previous episode that wizard was
sitting there waiting but nobody is
there alright let's see if we can get
anything out of these
i guess these refresh like each
[Music]
day slash evening because we ran through
here the first time
and got all these things i don't know if
we're gonna need to do it
every single time but right now we're
still
pretty early in the game it certainly
couldn't hurt to get a few more
items under our belt we definitely need
more beans like i said i want to make
sure that i can buy the
alohomora spell it might it might make
navigation quite a bit easier
but hopefully all you guys are doing
well out there in the uh
internet world and
where i live it's actually super warm
today you might notice me in the short
sleeves it got up to 80 degrees here so
feeling really nice right now and my
son's
playing baseball again this year he
turned seven this week guys
seven years old for my oldest
marauding with monsters by gilderoy
lockhart interesting okay so this is not
the book we were after
but let's take a look at this here
during my myriad travels across the
magical globe of ours
across this magical globe of ours i've
beheld many strange sights and
encountered a
veritable bestiary of peculiar and
exotic creatures
are we gonna oh wow okay this is pretty
long we're not gonna read all this
we're not going to read every single uh
page here but
so there we got the gnomes we already
checked those guys out at
the weasleys uh what are these the imps
here i guess
they're called uh
gnomes are rather more threatening than
the inert and somewhat tedious horclump
these little pests are endemic to even
the most well-tended garden
and then this guy
why does it not okay imps cluster of
imps all right
i was like why does it not say exactly
what he is come on lockhart
i mean he is kind of a fraud anyway
right fire crab
the dire dog spirits dude that's a
pretty cool design
get trashes or ghee trashes geetrishes
let me know if in the comments if you
guys know how exactly that's supposed to
be pronounced
because uh i remember me having a
question about that one in a
previous episode okay so the remember
all is is trying to tell me something
oh that is the horclump book okay nice
all right yeah so he yeah he took it
okay
so that's the whole book we've got that
now the next thing we need to do is find
the severing charm
i assume that's in the library as well
um like right here it would it would
help us get past that tapestry as well
okay we definitely can't go oh chocolate
frog
i don't really need the chocolate frog
but hey yeah we can't go in there
we don't have the spell to unlock that
yet at least i don't think so
it's not blue most no lumos
all right well let's try to go this way
there's the cauldron right there but
that cauldron's not going to help us
another very bought beam oh we need
incendio for that
hermione you didn't tell us where to
find the severing charm
or maybe she did she probably did dude
but it's been a little bit
since i i played this so i may have
forgotten where she said
okay so where were the severing charm i
mean would that be
on the charms floor we are on on
arn we are on the charms
level so perhaps it is in i don't know
like the charms clap wait what is this
reed
throwing gnomes can and perhaps should
evolve into a fascinating and rewarding
pastime there really is nothing like the
feeling one gets when clobbering one of
these ugly pests with a well-aimed
knockback jinx
and then flinging it over a low wall or
from a high wall
blah blah blah at hogwarts beating the
gnome flinging records will result in
the reward of a famous witches and
wizards god
which is always very gratifying indeed i
agree with that
it is very gratifying indeed actually i
didn't look to see if there were any
more pages in this let's see
okay just the one page are there hints
on all of these oh that's cool
okay broomstick information do any of
you
guys have where i can find
severing charms this hit right here nope
i feel like it would be pretty obvious
so
check out these hints though throwing
gnomes like why are you still talking
about gnomes are all
are all of these hints just about the
gnomes right here
that's a little overkill uh this is
about incendio right here insidiou charm
has been utilized
okay all right might as well complete
okay there's none over there
all right well well okay so we've gotten
that
now we need to go find i don't think
it's in here guys
i do not think it's in the library
unless it's in this room
dude what if it's in here somewhere
where i actually have to sneak around to
get it
i don't think so though okay let's go
oh i thought that might be a hidden
portrait or something
so one would think since it's a severing
charm
that it would be somewhere on the charms
floor here because
that's what this floor is uh designated
as charms and the library annex
oh man i don't know if i should be back
here or not guys
i do not know if i should be here it's
this oh
beans yes yes please
[Music]
i think we've been here before this
looks very familiar
oh my goodness dude this thing is loaded
with birdie bop beans
more okay that's the last one that's the
last one right there
three let's count on four five six
seven eight oh they're starting to
disappear
nine ten ten birdy bop beans out of
these things
let's go three
four
and that's it yep okay well
i mean that was worth it that was worth
coming in here just for those 30 beans
see if there's anything else all right
i don't think there's anything else in
this room unless
any secret passage dude i forgot to
check for secret passages in the library
oh my goodness no all those birdie bop
beans that we just obtained
see i i really don't like that you can't
get them when they're like that
i really don't like that so this is
going to take us to a different floor
that's not what we want
let me buy it dude let me buy all right
let's go back out here
let's try the other door okay let me
make sure oh there's three more doors to
try here
all right yeah second floor is charms
and the library
[Music]
i gotta watch out for these books man
all right how many video games can you
say that about
i gotta watch out for these books
these enchanted books okay well that is
not where we want to be
all right so there's only one more
option here
incendio challenge chambers what
okay so libra annex let me go in there
wait did i try this one
girl's bathroom
uh i apologize i just need to uh
is there a severing charm in here by
chance
okay wait so where would we find the
settering charm then
transfiguration
oh no oh no
well if nothing else this is resulting
in a pretty solid
birdie bot beanz run no way through
there
i love how to let you try even though it
says locked
oh this is a classroom
dude there's one of those hands again
i bet that's supposed to keep the
wizards from like sneaking around
after hours all right well you know we
obviously gotta
we gotta go through and check all these
now
don't do it you gotta walk slowly harry
actually i think if i do it while i'm
holding
holding the left
shoulder button oh man see like come on
let me grab that let me grab that
can i blast it with the flipindo
okay all right so let's let's try
i'm scared
oh i can't search yeah there we go
nothing in that one okay
i'm just gonna go back like this
oh you know there's got there should be
something extra special in this one
[Music]
come on just one of those balloons
really really that's all you got
nothing what a waste of time
oh what a waste of time
be serious
come on dude
ready about beans all right stink pellet
yeah i think i don't need to sneak
anymore when i'm this far away from it
all right welp okay we tried that door
like where else would a severing charm
be if not on
the charms level you guys
classroom 1b oh jeez what are you doing
oh no she's coming back she's coming
back again
okay so wait what did this one say this
one actually said classroom 1b
what where's classroom 1a
is this classroom 1a
like turn around this camera in this
game is
pretty wonky at times okay that one's
locked all right
oh this is like in the main when you
first enter hogwarts right there yeah
the grand staircase
that's locked oh but then this will
slide over
oh where does this lead guys this leads
straight down is that just the door to
the outside
or to the entrance hall yeah okay that
goes to the entrance hall
all right i don't think we should go in
the entrance hall
so let's head back up here
for those of you who remember and have
played this game you're probably just
screaming at the screen right now here's
where you go
as part of the fun of doing these though
like after all this time
[Music]
because there are so many things that
like as soon as it happens like oh yeah
i remember that
but then other things like right now
clearly
i do not remember this specific mission
at all okay so we've got two
two more doors we can open on this floor
and more classrooms
it's in a different position in here
come on open up i'm gonna regret this
aren't i
i'm gonna regret going through every
single one of these
come on give me something cool
what a shame what a shame
are you serious is every single desk in
this
classroom gonna be empty no way
no way all right well that was a waste
of time but hey
you don't even have birdie bop beans for
me get out of here
get out of here okay we haven't tried
this one yet
i mean even if even if we don't find the
charm like down here i am enjoying
exploring this because
i need to do that anyway to try and
remind myself of where everything is
again
so the this first level here has quite a
few
classrooms but it looks like none of
them oh there we go cauldron cake
are what we need for oh goodness i
almost ran
none of them are working oh geez that
scares me every
time i didn't think i was running that
fast
i really didn't think i was moving that
fast i'm sorry hand of glory
i'm sorry
okay let's go we got it we got a creep
man
we got we just got a little bit lacks
right there you know
a little bit lacks and that was all it
took to lose those beans
got a few of them back but not all
okay let's slide over again
it's just a waste of time dude i don't
even know why i'm checking them anymore
i don't even know why oh forget it i'm
out of here
severing charm please have any of you
seen a severing charm
okay that's the class oh my god he's the
ghost again
at least with the ghost like you can get
them back
relatively easily whereas when that
hand hits you when it throws them around
the desk it's a little bit harder
all right i still maintain i feel like
they should be on the charms floor
but when in doubt let's just go ask you
know what maybe defense against the dark
guards
maybe
even though i mean that's not really
what a separate charm is
okay so this is weird this just leads
like straight down there you can
take that as kind of a shortcut to the
charms floor but
that's weird it's not a hidden there's
nothing
hidden there so what is the point of
that
exactly i feel like that actually
matters later in the game
i want to say it comes into play
oh okay this is the defense against the
nope stay back
stay back you enchanted books
[Music]
all right fine yeah
[Music]
all right yeah we need to build back up
our birdie bop beans let's get up to
100.
okay so what is this right here
classroom 3c so that right there is
defense against the dark arts
something tells me it's not in a
classroom
like i said though i am enjoying the
exploration anyway
and this music doesn't it just scream
like forbidden
you should not be out right now oh
dumbledore's office
and what is this oh it's open another
classroom
do they have a little hand of glory out
yes they do
all right you know what i'm gonna make
the decision that
it's not even worth it
it's not even worth it for the chance
that i'll find like one bean or
something in there
it's not gonna bother all right i will
try going in the defense against the
dark arts classroom
the door's locked okay door's locked all
right
well you know what when in doubt let's
go ask hermione let's see what she has
to say
okay hermione we're counting on you here
do you
have the answer now that you know how to
pull up pork clubs okay
you're going to have to use that
knowledge to get into the greenhouse
again
[Music]
why would the spell be in the herbology
greenhouse
okay and the other thing that means is
that we actually need to
read the book so we need to pull out
that book again and let's
take a closer look let's see does it
show up anywhere
look of spell school records yeah it's
in this one right here
now this is actually kind of cool i like
that they have these books in here
whoops didn't mean to close out
that you actually keep in your inventory
and it's not just like
some random collectible thing like
there's actually a point to it
it's not gonna say here's how you do it
unless you read the book you know so you
actually have to go through here i think
that's kind of cool instead of just you
know spoon feeding you the information
all right so let's read what he says
about how
to deal with [ __ ] clumps here okay so
the usual technique for uprooting
horclumps
is to take a good firm hold on them then
twist and yank them from the ground
needless to say when i had cleared the
pathway of every last horcrunt my fans
were more than grateful
more than grateful and rewarded me with
several bottles of their home brewed
celery and beetroot wine which of course
i promptly declined
i don't buy that lockhart i don't buy
that okay but like
it seems pretty straightforward uh you
just
um take a good firm hold and twist and
yank
okay all right well i don't know that
was
maybe i praised it too soon maybe i
praised the game too soon
because let's be honest here i do think
that is something
that i could have likely figured out on
my own okay i don't
i haven't memorized yet which way
everything is so
will you tell me or do i have to walk
all the way over there okay so that's
forbidden forest
that is like quidditch right
yeah okay quidditch stadium see it pops
up just a second before you
dude there's hagrid over there and now
hagrid's missing what watch this
watch this if i run to the quidditch
stadium and then i turn back this way
there he is up there he's just standing
there
but then when i go back here
he's gone okay what about this way
greenhouse three excellent excellent is
hagrid out here dude you hanging around
no
okay
not gonna lie dude it's actually just a
tad bit creepy out here
it's actually just a little bit creepy
out here at night
but i love all the sounds here in the
greenhouse
all right where's this book this is just
something i walk up and
grab or do we need to do some sort of
challenge ooh there are some
nasty looking plants in there that i
don't know
we are ready to encounter
what is this potions kit bag oh
somebody was looking for that weren't
they okay here we go
yeah oh goodness
it's like the hand of glory you gotta
sneak up on them
okay do i need to cast a spell first
[Applause]
get away
that's funny dude
away yeah i don't know that i needed to
read the book for this
i think i could have figured it out and
honestly i don't know i don't think the
book even mentioned anything about
having to cast the spell first
all right out of my way okay so it's
probably gonna be in here then right
it's probably gonna be in here you would
think
oh dude there's a lot going on in here
man
there's a lot going on in here
oh there's a bunch of them over there
only a couple right here
all right out of my way oh come on
see i got just a little too greedy i got
just a little too greedy
all right fine i'll cast the spell again
there you go
and toss you out of the way and i think
i saw it
yep there we go there we go
now do we have to use the spell to get
out of here that's the question
will we need the severing charm severing
severally severs ropes and tapestries as
is the case with many grade 2 spells
the defendo severing charm has a variety
of uses for example defendo can be cast
on certain tapestries or wall
hangings to reveal heretofore
hidden entrances students of herbology
can also use defendo to sever plant
stems and roots okay so that's probably
why they have it out here in the
herbology area so i'm gonna put it on
let's see
x instead of the uh whatever this
those stink pellets were i don't really
need those right now
oh and of course now these guys decide
to show up
now you decide to show up
oh yeah i do remember decendo
having a really cool animation or wait
what is it defendo yeah diffendo
oh look at this guy man look at this guy
oh dude that thing just tried to reach
out and
okay i'm done they look like they were
getting more
angry every time i did that so
you know what i'm good but now i am
curious about these other sections
is there anything in here any special
collectible
nothing okay
just had to check you never know when
there's going to be a wizard card just
hanging out in the herbology greenhouse
[Applause]
like i mean are they just here for the
looks there's nothing else for me to do
in here
come on nope okay
all right let's go get neville guys
let's go get him out from behind the
tapestry
now the other cool thing about this is
we now
can get to some of those other areas in
the library
in fact really anywhere that we've seen
a tapestry
we should make a mental note to go and
and check back so now that we have this
charm here
okay so we need to go back into the
grand staircase
oh goodness here we go again dude to me
let me rip you
let me tell you
what was that when's he gonna start
saying
kill kill
let me tear you oh goodness oh
no what it's already starting mr potter
oh oh crap dude
i didn't expect this to happen so soon i
don't know
i found him like this follow me
did you catch the spiders did you catch
the spiders dude professor
i swear i didn't
oh no dumbledore's office dude
here we go here we go i did i wasn't
expecting this to happen so soon
in the game came across the sorting hat
you've been wondering whether i put you
in the right house
yes but you were particularly difficult
to play indeed but i stand by what i
said before
you would have done well in slytherin
and they just they just leave it at that
in the game dumbledore's pet phoenix
let's go
fox fascinating creatures phoenixes
they can carry immensely heavy loads
their tears old albus powers and they
make highly
faithful pets and of course
professor dumbledore himself
i know harry psych dude
but i put your hand on my shoulder man
whether there is anything you'd like to
tell me calm
come on harry just tell him dude just
tell him
let me rip that made me so mad when i
was reading that book
as a kid like dude what just tell him
he's like
nah they might they might send me home
they might not allow me to stay in
hogwarts very well
if you're sure good night harry
now watch are they gonna make me sneak
back are they gonna make me sneak back
into the glass or into the uh gryffindor
tower
no they totally do see i feel like you
should have some sort of like hall pass
where they're like
okay he's good like we know he's up he
better be going straight back
to griffin the gryffindor common room or
he's in big trouble
all right so let's go harry all right
hermione we've got it
at the tapestry you got it
oh he's just standing back there thanks
harry
i thought i was never gonna get out of
there i thought he was like
actually like trapped up against it you
know
i think i'll head off to bed no he's
just like standing there nearly had this
nigga's been attacked and i
oh i'll tell you in the morning
cool so are we gonna get a wizard card
yeah dude wizard card
oh i need to go over to fred george's as
well number 65
gondoline oliphant gondoline
oliphant famous for studies of life and
habits of trolls club to death
okay that that took a dark turn
club to death into cotswolds while
sketching
geez there's a couple of these that are
pretty gruesome
come on man
look at look at that porch to the cat
that's great
all right i don't think there's anything
else like neville dude how did you even
get in here that's that's the question i
have
all right is this the way to yeah i
think this is bretton george's
[Music]
dude what are you even doing in here
percy like for real man
oh no go the other way are you serious
come here
[Music]
there's no way he should know i'm over
here yeah i was about to say
he should definitely take a turn right
there where did he go
i'm right here liberty
flippity jibbet
all right let me in here dude i probably
don't even have enough to buy anything
watch
i think i have over 70 though right i
really want to get the spell book but i
think it's a hundred more spell book
130 every flavor beans okay
so did i buy let's see
that's an extra thing for the wigan weld
potion i don't really need that
stink pellets are a great way to stop
prefix catching you
i mean i could just start buying wizard
cards how much is that
30 30 bucks every flavor beans all right
what about this thing
balloon holster what does this cost 20
30 bucks
20. okay that would let me hold more how
many can i hold right now
you can hold 15.
[Music]
and so they got wizard card was a card
how many is the wicked world potion vial
130 votes yeah that's 102 i kind of feel
like i should wait to be honest
i feel like i really do feel like i
should wait
because i i mean aloha mora that's
probably the most important thing in
here
i can i can get wizard cards in game
right i can come back later and get
wizard cards
all right so we took care of neville we
got him set free we
found the spell we found the book on
[ __ ] clumps and
it completed that task so we also
unfortunately found nearly headless nick
has indeed been petrified so i think
that's a good spot for us to end
this video we'll see you next time if
you're new here and this your first time
watching make sure you give it a thumbs
up
as always guys thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon